hi everyone and welcome to biology
professor today we're going to be
discussing the different ways in which
organisms obtain two essential things
those are carbon and energy we know that
life is carbon-based and life needs
energy in order to grow and develop and
so that's why the sources of carbon and
energy are great ways to categorize
organisms so we have organisms that are
categorized in the different ways in
which they obtain these two things
carbon and energy let's talk first about
different carbon sources organisms that
obtain their carbon from various organic
sources in their environment are called
heterotrophs the other way in which some
organisms can obtain carbon is through
environmental carbon dioxide that is
carbon dioxide contains carbon and some
organisms can take it up and harvest it
for use in other ways these organisms
are called autotrophs
organisms can also be categorized based
on their energy sources for example
those organisms that get their energy
from the sunlight
are called phototrophs and of course
there are many organisms that can't just
directly generate energy for their own
use from sunlight and those organisms
instead oxidize various inorganic
chemicals to obtain their energy and
these are called chemo troughs now of
course all organisms need both of these
things all organisms need carbon and all
organisms need energy and this means
that these categories can be combined to
create four different types of organisms
photo
autotrophs photo heterotrophs
chemoautotrophs and chemoheterotroph
let's talk about some examples of each
one of these photo autotrophs are those
organisms that are getting their energy
from the sunlight and their carbon from
environmental carbon dioxide so these
include organisms like plants also algae
as well as cyanobacteria which is a type
of bacteria you may have heard of photo
heterotrophs are still getting their
energy from sunlight but rather than
using the environmental carbon dioxide
they're getting their carbon from
organic sources these include a couple
of types of bacteria that most people
haven't heard of called purple and green
non sulfur bacteria
chemoautotrophs the next type of
category includes organisms that get
their energy from inorganic chemicals
and their carbon from environmental
carbon dioxide chemoautotrophs include a
lot of the organisms that we think of as
extremophiles this refers to things like
halophiles salt-loving bacteria
methanogens the bacteria and archaea
that live in deep-sea ocean vents these
are all types of extremophiles that are
falling into the category of
chemoautotrophs now finally that fourth
category is chemo heterotrophs so these
are organisms that are getting their
energy from inorganic chemicals that are
metabolized in some way to extract the
energy and they're getting their carbon
from organic sources so organic sources
perhaps things that they eat or take up
in some way in order to harvest the
carbon from them the best examples of
chemo heterotrophs and the ones that
we're all familiar with are members of
the animal kingdom including humans
so that is it for today learning about
the carbon and energy sources of various
organisms I hope you learned a lot and
thanks for watching biology professor